everyone loves Rober W your relationship
with on set sounded fractious well he
was incredibly funny very relaxed and
very inventive and he would get up he
would just improv constantly all day
long and the more the crew laughed the
more he encourage he was come on
louder y'all good God boy like there it
is I really wanted to be a serious actor
and I really didn't want to laugh the
more I didn't laugh the more insane he
got and would make fun of oh this one
doesn't want to laugh he didn't
understand I was trying to do a good job
you know I want to be Montgomery Cliff
over here you're trying to be zero
mustell or something so I thought he
hated me CU he just constantly would lay
into me and when the movie was over I
had to go back to school and I got this
call you know this guy says I'm I'm
Robin Williams agent he says that you're
going to be somebody and that I should
sign you and I was like really he got me
my first agent who's still my agent now
so lovely